.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, ANDY.
STANDBY HERE.
WE ARE WAITING FOR REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE THAT DECISION
IN.
SHANNON BREAM, ARE YOU HERE?
>> YES, THIS IS A LONG ONE BUT
WE ARE GETTING THROUGH THIS.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE CHIEF JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS AND
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH JOINED WITH
THE LIBERAL THREE JUSTICES FOR A
5-4 DECISION IN FAVOR OF THE
BIDEN DECISION FOR NOW FOR THIS
ONE IS COMPLICATED.
THE GOVERNMENT'S DECISION OF
THAT REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY DID
NOT VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW.
THEY SAY THIS OCTOBER 29TH
MEMORANDUM.
TO TRY TO GET RID OF THIS REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY DIDN'T
CONSTITUTE FINAL AGENCY ACTIONS
BUT REVERSING THE
COURT OF APPEALS WAS DECIDED
AGAINST THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SENDING THIS CASE BACK DOWN FOR
FURTHER PROCEEDINGS.
THIS IS A WIN AT FIRST BLUSH AT
FIRST-RATE OVERVIEW FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS
BEEN TRYING TO GET RID OF REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY.
>> FOR NOW, IT LOOKS LIKE A FIVE
HUNDRED FOUR DECISION THAT
SHOULD MAKE THE WHITE HOUSE
HAPPY AFTER A WEEK WHERE THEY
FOUND A REAL BROCK SPACK OF
EVERYTHING THEY'VE BEEN TRYING
TO DO IN THEIR POLICIES.
DOES LOOK LIKE THE FINAL PHASE
OF THAT TERM IS GOING TO BE ONE
THAT WILL MAKE THE WHITE HOUSE
HAPPY.
>> Dana: YOU KEEP READING.
THAT SPRING IN TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
WHO HAS BEEN GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO
JOIN US THIS MORNING.
WE'RE JUST GETTING THIS IN.
504 DECISION ON A TECHNICALITY.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THIS TOO.
WHAT ARE YOU HOPING TO SEE HERE,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
POLICIES IN PLACE THAT CAN TREAT
THE MIGRANTS WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY.
AT THE SAME TIME, HAVE
REPERCUSSIONS.
WE FOLLOW THE LAWS BECAUSE
OTHERWISE, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A RECORD NUMBER
OF MIGRANTS COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE GOING TO
BE RELEASED ON OUR STREETS.
I WANT TO REPLACE THE POLICIES
HAVE TO BE IN A CENTRAL WAY THAT
IT DOESN'T -- MORE PEOPLE ARE
COMING TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Dana: FOR YOUR AREA, YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, YOUR DISTRICT, THE
IDEA OF REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY
IS TO TRY TO HAVE A PROCESS
HERE, NOT SWAMP THE BORDER
PATROL.
LET'S HAVE THEM REMAIN IN
MEXICO.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TRIED
TWICE TO GET RID OF IT.
DID YOU EVER ADVISE THEM THAT
WAS A BAD DECISION?
>> MY POSITION HAS BEEN THAT IN
THIS CASE, IF YOU HAVE A REMAIN
IN MEXICO AND THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO AN ATTORNEY THEY WANT TO COME
AND PRESENT THEIR CASE, AND THEY
ARE IN A SAFE SITUATION, THEN WE
OUGHT TO DO THAT.
OTHERWISE, YOU HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT COME IN, COME INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE GIVEN
FALSE HOPE BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE
A HUNDRED PEOPLE, ONLY 10-12%
ARE GIVEN ASYLUM.
ONLY 10% TO 12% ARE GOING TO BE
GIVEN ASYLUM.
WHY ARE WE LETTING 100% AND WE
SHOULD BE ALLOWING ONLY 10% OR
12% OF THOSE PEOPLE COME INTO
THE UNITED STATES?
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
BEEN AWAY FOR FIVE DAYS AT NATO
FOR A MEETING.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING BACK HOME.
THERE IS THE ROE V. WADE
DECISION.
IT IS THE FACT THAT INFLATION
AND GAS PRICES CONTINUE.
CRIME ACROSS THE BORDER.
EXCUSE ME, ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND THE REALLY BIG ISSUE.
THE BORDER IS A MAJOR ISSUE.
GRIFF JENKINS HAS BEEN THERE FOR
SIX DAYS.
HE COUNTED 9,000 PEOPLE CAME
ACROSS.
DO YOU THINK BIDEN WILL EVER
TURN HIS ATTENTION TO THE BORDER
IN A SERIOUS WAY BEFORE THE
MIDTERM?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW.
I FEEL BAD FOR THE -- SO MANY
ISSUES HAPPENING IN THE
UNITED STATES DOMESTICALLY AND
ACROSS THE WORLD, DEALING WITH
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
I FEEL, YOU KNOW, BAD FOR HIM.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE WERE
PEOPLE THAT CAN IMPLEMENT THE
LAWS THAT WE HAVE ON THE BOOKS
ALREADY TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS REPERCUSSIONS.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE, AND WE FINISH
THIS FISCAL YEAR WHICH WILL BE
ON SEPTEMBER 30TH, WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A RECORD NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THIS IS WHY CERTAIN POLICIES
LIKE TITLE 42 ARE IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN PLACE WHILE WE LOOK AT
THE SITUATION AT THE BORDER.
THERE IS NO REPERCUSSIONS WHERE
PEOPLE WILL RETURN UNDER TITLE
EIGHT OR TITLE 42.
THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP COMING
INTO THE UNITED STATES AND
LARGE, LAR